Còn cục công an khu rạng cầm buổi chiều và bà mềm ủ thống một thông báo,
lực lượng trực năng lúc này đã mở một chiến dịch Tui Quét,
bùi mô lớn nhằm báo mọi lời tội phạm lời đạo trực tuyến,
tại thành của Bà Vét ở tình Sway R.
Hống viên thục tự sợ Việt Nam tại film vying dẫn báo thông bây thống ở YouTube,
trên dịch được đến hành cùng sự phối hợp của Việt Kim Sot,
tình Sway R.
Trong khi đó tự cố sản tế phép, được tin,
trên dịch trên có sự thông ra của khoảng bẩy trăm nhân viên an link,
nhằm báo khu phức hợp sống bảo văn trong quá trình Tui Quét,
lượng trung năng cà buổi chiều đã bắt dữ hợp hành in đi phạm,
mọi người cũng tích khăn nhau.
Cung ngay phó chút tích đảng nhân dân cà buổi chiều càm quyền Man Sam An,
đã chỉ thì có lượng trung năng tăng cường trên át tổ phạm công nghệ,
để bảo vệ xem tính của ra trong mất khách rùl định và nhé được tự của tế.
Lông thơ khẳng định viện Tui Quét tổ phạm lời đạo trực tuyến là UTN trên lượng
nhằm vui chiều, để kinh tế của cảm ưu trung đỏ bộ thông tin cảm ưu trung biết trong trên dịch trình át tổ phạm
lời đạo xử dụng công nghệ trên phạm viên toàn quốc trong mấy tháng qua.
Lưu lời trường năng sở tải đã bắt dữ năng nghệ một trong lệ sống viên phạm thuộc 2,5 hút tích.
Chúc sất của mình năng trang 8 mệt tự đối tượng.